you know that wave that you feel or your
tongue gets numb or you get tightness in
your cheeks or you freeze you know when
that happens based on the science there
is only a 90-second chemical release in
your body it's called the 90-second rule
the stomach starts to flutter when your
heart starts to raise based on the
science there's a 90-second rule and all
of the chemical release that's happening
because your body is going into a state
of being alert it only sticks around for
90 seconds as long as you don't let your
thoughts race if your thoughts start to
race you'll start to agitate the
situation so the next time that your
body goes into a state of alert when the
body starts to do that it means your
body is getting ready to be alert and
pay attention it does not mean you're in
danger it does not mean to stop or to
shut up I want you to take a deep breath
foreign
count to five five four three two one
exit and realize that the hormones that
just got released because you're about
to do something they only last 90
seconds that's it you can breathe slowly
you can count to 90. you can get up and
walk around you can do 90 seconds of
jumping jacks you can meditate for 90
seconds you can ground your feet in your
chair and wiggle a minute so that you
feel your body in your chair
[Music]
[Applause]
take deep breaths and what you're going
to find is that you're going to be blown
away you're going to be blown away
because what you're going to see is that
in 90 seconds flat you can go from being
somebody who has an upset stomach and
who would normally not go talk to your
boss who would normally not walk into
that gym who would normally not make
that call in 90 seconds flat you can
manipulate your body state to calm down
and you will notice that your thoughts
do not race your thoughts calm down
you're in full control and now you can
speak up and now you can show up so I'm
here in Puerto Rico I was invited to
speak at Brendan burchard's Mastermind
event these people pay 30 to 50 000 a
year to be a part of his group and I was
asked to speak I was one of two external
speakers to be here over the past three
days and before going on stage I had a
little mini panic attack
my biggest fears are going to disappoint
people my biggest fear is going to let
them down my biggest fear is that
Brendan you know brought me over here
put me up in this amazing Hotel you know
and uh and I'm gonna forget what I'm
gonna say I'm gonna let people down I'm
gonna disappoint them and it's gonna
look bad for everybody and they paid all
this money to be here and just before
going on stage in the introduction
Brendan's talking about how I've helped
him and how helped him with his YouTube
channel and just backstage I dropped all
these genius knowledge bombs on him and
in my heart I'm like freaking out even
more as I can man as if I wasn't already
stressed out enough You're Gonna Bump me
up and fill me up even more which in my
head is more expectations uh you know
what people think I'm gonna do people
who may not even know me now they're
gonna be you know putting all these
expectations on me right now I have to
deliver even more right after the big
setup I'd rather under promise and over
deliver not have a giant promise and
then try to match it so
here's the thing that saves me
and maybe it'll work with you
I default to service when I'm stressed
out when I'm anxious this happens mostly
when
when we're afraid of other people's
opinions right when when we're about to
make a YouTube video when we're about to
speak on stage we're about to do
something like talking to a customer
something scary it's usually because of
other people's opinions
and what I do is default to service when
I can catch it right if you catch
yourself feeling the panic attack
default the service so I'll look at it
to the crowd and remind myself I'm not
here for me I'm here for them
I'm here for you I'm making this video
for you hopefully you know this channel
is a part of your regular routine your
morning routine and it's giving you
inspiration and ideas and belief and
hope in the morning that's why I make
these videos it's not because I love
standing out here on the balcony with my
arm about to fall off because I'm tired
of holding this phone up right
I'm introverted I have no desire to to
see myself on camera every time before
filming I have these moments of anxiety
feeling like
I want the new video I make to be better
than before and so I get nervous and
scared every time I I get even still now
in front of the camera to make videos
like this but definitely to do crazy uh
speeches in front of people paying 30 to
50K to be there right
it's about service you're built to serve
you want to help other people give a
message that matters and so my technique
that always calms me down and always
makes me feel great is I think this is
about you this is about them this isn't
about me
I did the same thing two weeks ago when
I was in Whistler
um at my left and Andy priscella flew me
out to speak to their group and these
guys face 60k a year to be there there's
a hundred people in the room super uh
super limited super Elite and David
Goggins spoke first and then I spoke
after him and then Peyton Manning spoke
after me
and I'm thinking man
I gotta speak between David Goggins and
Peyton Manning are you kidding me
and so the hamster wheel starts running
right who am I to be here oh my gosh
these guys are are so crazy and like
Elite of the elite and I'm gonna I'm
gonna disappoint people I'm gonna let
people down right that's the thought
process and I get anxiety Then
but then I remind myself this about the
surface that the people here I care
about and they're thought leaders and
experts and they need to get their
message out and I know more about
YouTube than David Goggins and Peyton
Manning so let's go right that's that's
the voice inside my head that's how I
get myself
into action mode so it's not about being
Fearless
I think if you have those moments where
you feel anxious where you feel nervous
we feel scared it's actually good if you
don't have anything that makes you feel
nervous ancient scared you're you have a
boring life you don't like your life
you're bored because you're doing the
same thing over and over and over again
you want things that are different you
want things that are outside your
comfort zone you want things to stretch
you and that comes with anxiety and
insecurities and fears and doubts that's
all normal but what you don't want to
teach yourself is that when you get
afraid you play small when you get
anxious you back down right that's not
the message it's through you do it you
rise up when you do it and the way to do
it at least for me is one telling myself
I'm Evan Carmichael and I do scary
things right scary difficult to heart I
do those things
but then to default the service
that this is not about you don't be so
selfish
you have a message that can change the
world your responsibility to get it out
there to help people and you staying
quiet and you staying small doesn't
serve anybody
you're built to serve now go live it
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all of the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
one of the most important things when
you're in a situation where the truth
the facts are that there is more on your
plate than one human being can
effectively handle on his or her own
there's a really important moment where
you have to surrender
to the chaos
that your life is for the next couple
weeks things are going to change when
summer hits
but part of what I find personally
is that when I resist and I do resist I
resist what's actually happening when
that's not the way that I want things to
go and so if you start complaining or
you start bringing extra weight to all
of the things that are going on it's
gonna make it feel even more
overwhelming and if you can bring a
sense of realism to it so I call this
and I think Sean anchors the one that
came up with this this this term
realistic optimism
realistic optimism is a really powerful
mindset because
you're not just putting a sunny spin on
a crappy situation
you're being realistic about where you
are in your life right now
and you are still
maintaining an optimistic point of view
and what that means is that you when
you're an optimist you believe that your
actions and your thoughts matter
you believe that you can handle what's
on your plate you believe that based on
your thoughts and your actions you can
positively affect the outcome of
whatever it is that you're dealing with
whether it's being wildly overwhelmed
because you're a single parent or
terrified because you just got a scary
Health diagnosis or you're spinning
because somebody just told you they
don't want to be in a relationship with
you anymore whatever it is that you're
facing that's making you feel
overwhelmed
first start with how important it is to
be a realistic optimist so there's a
surrendering to what's so but you're
going to stay very optimistic and
positive and know that everything that
you think and do is in your control and
that when you know that your behavior
matters it gives you a sense of
empowerment that's proven by research
super duper important it's also why you
can have a very hard life right now and
a very overwhelming life right now and
still be happy
because you know based on being a
realistic Optimist that this period will
pass and you know that there are things
that you can think about and do that are
within your control I think I am
um
engaged in emotional eating right now
uh it is 2 22 in the afternoon
um the wheels are off today
um I know why the reason why is because
I did not stick to my normal routine
and I've noticed since I did not stick
to my routine my day has sort of slid
off the rails in terms of the decisions
that I'm making
um it's really random like I had
my son's chicken nuggets for lunch and
there's half an apple that I ate I have
not finished the amount of water I
normally drink it is 223 and
I made myself an ice cream sundae
because you know why the hell not and so
as I'm sitting here enjoying my ice
cream sundae I just thought to myself
God
am I emotionally eating right now
oh my God this is so good
if I really unpack what I'm feeling
right now it's raining it's freezing I
am mentally in a creative block and I'm
gonna get this tool that we use on the
Mel Robbins show out I call it the word
wheel so I'm gonna show you the word
wheel right now
here's how you use a word wheel the
average person can only name three
emotions happy sad and angry
but our emotions are actually much
deeper and more complex and the secret
to getting unstuck or untriggered or
freed up in any situation is to find the
words that describe what you are truly
feeling so I'm going to start with the
core emotion of anger and fear and work
out from there
and so as I look at the word wheel
I feel inadequate as a writer
I feel worried
that I'm not going to have a creative
breakthrough
I feel helpless the big one is I feel
inadequate as a writer whoa big
breakthrough
my inadequate
scream Sunday
you know what's interesting is simply
finding the word
so I feel inadequate as a writer and
that makes me feel afraid that the book
isn't going to be good that it's not
going to be as good as I want it's not
going to do as well it's not going to
get any
um accolades or good reviews it's not
going to make a difference in your life
as you identify the feeling and for me
it's inadequate that Sunday doesn't
taste very good anymore
because it wasn't a Sunday that I was
craving it was reassurance and comfort
from this deeper feeling that I was
feeling
wow that's powerful stuff
really powerful stuff
so if you are at a moment where you
catch yourself emotionally eating
or you just feel untethered or numb pull
out the word wheel you can find it at
melrobbins.com
and
um I think you'll find it to be a really
incredible tool
that will help you locate what you're
truly working through and instead of
reaching for
an ice cream sundae which honestly is
going to now tank my mood because of all
the sugar and make me feel uh lethargic
if you can identify the word which for
me is inadequate
inferior worried
um frustrated uh you can let those
feelings rise up move through them and
then move on
two hours later and let me tell you the
impact of having fed my feelings first
of all I am totally bloated so I realize
that that's not big but you know for me
my stomach is just like oh
because all that sugar and dairy that I
just pounded down is now sitting here
like a rock and this is the problem with
emotional eating because you get caught
in this cycle where you feed these
feelings and then your body starts to
tank and your mood tanks and your
stomach gets bloated and so then you
start to make yourself wrong and feel
ashamed and feel like a bad person
because you did it
laughs
so how do you stop emotional eating
and what business do I have giving any
of us advice given that I just did it
well I'm going to tell you what I'm
going to do tomorrow when I inevitably
hit that creative block
is emotional eating you know that it's
emotional if it's uh comes on suddenly
if you aren't just craving something but
you are reaching for something that is a
treat or that's soothing and before I do
that tomorrow with my writer's block
inevitably happens again
I will take a deep breath and I will ask
myself what am I feeling
why am I reaching for this food am I
hungry or am I trying to soothe their
comfort or distract myself
because I was clearly trying to soothe
and distract myself from the feelings
that writer's block was bringing up and
now I need to get some gas sex or
something
because I gotta distract myself from the
gas pains that I have for my emotional
eating
but you know honestly the discomfort I'm
feeling right now that's not going to
stop me from doing it tomorrow the only
thing that will stop this pattern is
spotting the pattern and using the tools
that I just gave you identify what
you're feeling ask you why it is you're
reaching for this if you're not hungry
but you're trying to soothe distract or
reward yourself you're feeding some
feeling
recognize the feeling put down the ice
cream go for a walk choose something
healthy address the feeling
don't reach for the food the reticular
activity system the RAS for short
um for if you don't know what it is
picture a hair net over your brain that
is a live Network and the res is a
filter and it has a huge job and it is a
filter that blocks out 99 of the world
and lets in about you know point zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero one
percent and it is always changing there
are only four things Tom that get
through the hair net on your head the
sound of your name and you've
experienced this because you've been
walking through a crown you're like did
somebody say my name right the scale
party effect cocktail party effect the
second thing that gets through is any
sort of threat so if you hear a loud
noise and you go like this there are
lots of noises you didn't hear but the
loud when you kind of duck because it's
a threat the third thing is when your
partner is interested in sex with either
you or someone else that's why you're
like why are you checking that person
out right you know because the brain is
letting that information in the fourth
thing and this is where the
transformation
big ants
your brain will let in anything that it
believes is important to you the
zygarnic effect is the documented fact
that when something is important to you
and I'll explain what that means
your brain opens up a checklist in your
mind
and now your brain once it puts this
item on your checklist it will store the
checklist in your subconscious it's
encoded in your Ras and your mind is now
on the alert to spot things related to
it
the way that you make yourself feel like
something is important is your nervous
system goes on alert while you're
thinking about it you're either super
excited about something oh this is super
important or this is the trauma effect
you go on alert and you have something
really bad happen which is why
things continue to bring it up
throughout the rest of your life so when
you understand that if something's
important to you your filter will change
in real time how you see the world you
now know how to change your brain to
work for you and looking for hearts is
the way I'm going to prove to you that
this happens I want to give you one
other example because everybody's
experienced this if you've ever gone
shopping for a new car or you've dreamed
about having a new car what happens
immediately when you get excited about
that new car is your mind goes zygon
artifact oops okay Tom wants the new
Bronco that's cool so what do you see
now you see Broncos everywhere now they
were always there but your mind is
letting them in because the zygon
artifact
is now mated on a checklist it's changed
the res and so I am going to prove to
you that it is unbelievably cool that
you can change the way that you view the
World by looking for heart-shaped
objects so tomorrow when you wake up
you're going to start your day by
high-fiving yourself in the mirror I
want you to examine what the resistance
about because you're going to start to
then on be able to unpack what's holding
you back then you're going to go out in
the world and just like tell your mind I
want to see a heart today look for a
rock look for a leaf look in your like
lattes they're a little shape there is
there an oil stain on the floor and when
you see one stop and go
I I just I like there's a scavenger hunt
I never would have seen that before
thank you brain now your brain's like
more Hearts you will start to see hearts
everywhere and when you can start to
train your brain and realize whoa this
is actually a cool thing this is
high-fiving your mind when you can see
hearts you can now go wait a minute if I
can change what I see based on what I
tell it
maybe if I got serious about not
constantly saying I'm a failure I
wouldn't attach that or see it
everywhere maybe if I got serious about
saying I can figure anything out this is
happening for a reason instead of I'm
you say okay I'm gonna learn something
with this
it changes the way your brain filters
everything
and this is such an important piece to
the book because we've all had the
experience where you love somebody
deeply
and you see all their incredible
attributes and all they see is failure
or all they see is the weight that they
can't lose and it doesn't matter what
you say it doesn't matter what kind of
pep talk or support you give them
your loved one still only sees what they
hate about themselves blame the filter
in your brain you have been bitching
about your appearance or the weight on
your scale the fact that you're a
failure for so long your brain believes
it's important to you to see reasons why
this is true
and one of the things I gotta say about
this and everything in the book is the
tools are simple Tom
but it's super important to say
just because you change and start
celebrating yourself it's not going to
make the weight disappear suddenly
it doesn't change the number on the
scale overnight what it changes is you
and that changes your ability
to deal with the problems and the issues
you want to change in your life I wanted
to make this video because I know in
some area of your life you are wanting
to start something you're wanting to put
yourself out there more and you are
holding yourself back and one place that
I see this playing out all the time is
the fact that so many people probably
you are self-conscious and nervous about
putting videos online your
self-conscious and nervous about talking
about your business or sharing the
breakthroughs that you're having or just
showing up in a bigger Bolder more
self-expressed way because heck it makes
your life more fun when you do and so
you have this deep yearning to be doing
more and then I know exactly what
happens to you you look at the number of
people that follow you
you then say who the hell am I to say
that you then go nobody's going to watch
it anyway and I want to share with you
brand new research that blows that lame
excuse although normal excuse right out
of the water it was published literally
this month from Ohio State University
and it proves that when it comes to
video content the video content that
people find compelling has nothing to do
with the number of views that it has it
has to do with the person and the
message that's being communicated to be
compelling to make an impact to be
influential because I know everybody
wants to raise their influence and their
visibility and to show up in bigger ways
it is all about the message and you're
in control of that do you communicate
with passion do you have conviction
about what you're talking about you
could be talking about oh I don't know
uh whether you like white cords or these
like black cords with this end or
whether you like this kind of end or
this end or where you're like this cap
or whether you oh I love to drink this
way because I have a big nose and then
this way
and I'm telling you you don't have to
have this thing on you could literally
talk about anything and if you bring
passion and you bring conviction to what
you're talking about
people will pay attention that's what
real influence is it's the ability to
show up in ways and have conviction and
passion about the things that you
believe in whether you're talking about
a water bottle cap or you're talking
about how to be healthier happier or
more effective in your life so enough
with the excuses enough with worrying
about how many followers you have or
whether or not Aunt Sue is gonna like
the video or not or what people are
going to think
the only thing that matters is the
conviction and passion that you
communicate with and of course getting
started so based on the research
get started you have this Behavior
pattern where you snap you have this
Behavior pattern where you yell and you
get upset and you make people wrong and
you don't mean to
if you are somebody who's ever said to
yourself I wish I could stop yelling or
I wish I I I I I could just snap I could
stop snapping
this video is absolutely
unbelievable okay and the reason why is
I explained this research that was so
mind-blowing for me
it's called ghosts in the nursery a lot
of the patterns that you have that you
don't have control over are patterns
from your childhood
and they are there because when you were
a kid you experienced people in your
life that were tense did you ever have a
parent that was a Yeller
did you ever have a teacher that was a
yeller or a coach that was a yeller and
secretly in your little kid body
whenever your mom or dad would yell or
your coach would yell or your teacher
would yell or your grandmother or
grandfather would yell you would feel
tense right you would feel nervous you
would feel on edge of course that's how
we all feel right well here's the reason
why you might have an issue like I used
to have an issue where I would yell at
my kids and then I'd feel terrible about
it I'd snap at my husband and then I'd
feel terrible about it psychologist and
then I would say to myself I'm not doing
that again I'm not doing that again but
I wouldn't have the ability to end it
psychologists call this ghost in the
nursery it means that any situation
where you start to feel tense or you
start to feel stressed out guess what
happens your body remembers what it was
like when you were little to feel tense
and stressed out and what were the
adults doing around you when you felt
that way they were snapping they were
yelling and now here you are repeating
the pattern and you don't know why and
you feel guilty
and I'm explaining this to you because
it wasn't until I thought holy cow like
I know I don't want to snap at my
husband I know I don't want to take my
anger from work out on my family why
can't I stop this
that's the reason why it's because it's
a pattern that you remember from being a
kid that the adults around you were
snapping or yelling or being mean
any time and when they were you felt
tense and stressed out so now that
you're an adult when you're tense and
stressed out you repeat the behavior
that you witnessed crazy right so how do
you stop it well the first step to
stopping anything is to actually
understand what you're dealing with
now that you know you're dealing with a
pattern now all you need to do is
basically say okay I'm going to put a
practice in place it's going to
interrupt this pattern what's the
practice well a really good one is
um before you walk in the house at the
end of the day if you're stressed out
Take Five
take five deep breaths like reset your
mood reset your energy before you walk
in the house and you'll be surprised by
how much nicer you are to the people
around you another thing that um that uh
you can do and this one's not so fun is
you can train your partner your kids
your roommates your family that if
you're trying to get a hold of how you
bring stress home you can train them to
say to you hey don't take your work
stress out on me when somebody that you
care about says that to you it's a
humbling experience and the person that
says it the most in my life is my son
Oakley your uh the youngsters seem to
love to cross-check the adults so be
careful with taking that advice we
encourage people to break boundaries you
know they feel like they're limited but
you talk about uh your boundaries are
that has served you so obviously it's a
different type of boundary but
you know yeah so so here's the thing
what boundaries do you need to help
yourself to protect yourself and which
ones do you need to grow past that are
holding you back
I think that the definition with
boundaries that has helped me the most
is understanding the boundaries are for
me they're not for you and the single
biggest mistake that we make in any
relationship particularly romantic ones
but also work related ones is we do not
express what we need any pattern can be
replaced yeah change isn't personal just
feels personal change is just about
identifying patterns and replacing them
with new ones that's it and and it'll
take a little while because they're
encoded in your nervous system and your
default is to just do it yourself
um but you have to you cannot as a rule
punish other people you didn't
communicate right so I'll give you the
perfect example so Chris and I have been
married for 24 years
and when I was before the talk show and
I made my living mostly by uh you know
doing a hundred speeches a year
I would be on the road 150 days a year
and when I would come home there was
always something that pissed me off
like what like uh the trash is taken out
the clothes are here or is it something
else oh no I'm way worse than that are
you kidding I would walk in after being
gone for five or six days
and they're on the island in the kitchen
was a vase that had Dead Flowers the
ones that I had bought for myself a week
before and it was as if everybody in my
family had been walking around the
island for six days as if there was some
dead flower sculpture in the middle of
the island and so I would come home and
first of all the only person that's
really excited to see me is a dog and my
family did sit me down at one point they
said you know you realize when you're
not here we have our own lives so you
don't put your lives on hold while you
know for us and we're not putting our
lives on hold so it's not that we're not
excited to see you but we're not
organizing our whole lives around when
Mom comes home
to be like the dog excited and running
up and jumping in your arms and kissing
you yeah yeah no no but that but I think
that's cool because that means that
they're independent and doing their own
thing they've set boundaries they've set
boundaries with me perfect so for
probably six months I would get pissy
and I would walk in and put my bags down
and I grabbed the flowers and I
demonstrably how many times has everyone
done this throw them out loudly like
everyone hears you communication yeah
I'm getting my communication just
throwing these dead flowers out
communicate to you that you should buy
me flowers like I'm not saying that but
that's what the body language is right
how dare I have been off I've been in
four cities and then you become a Mart
like ugh I'm just disgusting when I tell
the story but this is it this is like
so well I see you've got some lovely
flowers behind you that look alive so
that's good to see I want their flight
I just said to Chris
you know what would make me feel amazing
is if when I came home
you had just bought some flowers just go
to the just when you're at the grocery
store it doesn't you don't have to order
like I'm saying buy the five dollar pack
of half dead tulips just something okay
and and then he said why
and this is the most important part of
expressing and look you don't have to
give an explanation if you're trying to
like cut off a toxic person but if you
want to express boundaries with somebody
because you want them to understand you
more deeply give them the why I said
because it makes me think
that you are excited for me to come home
and that you knew I was coming
because I'm starting to feel forgotten
so underneath the anger Lewis wow
was hurt
and feeling like I didn't matter
and so I'll be darned I walk in
and
um there they are and I literally feel
so seen you gotta be honest with
yourself
if there are things about your
appearance that are within your control
whether it is the shape that you're in
whether it's the health choices that
you're making whether it's how you take
care of yourself in terms of self-love
and you're not taking action in those
areas the lack of action says to your
brain
you don't care about yourself and so
what I want you to do is pick one thing
one behavior that you could do every day
the high fives one of them pick another
one and I want you to practice doing it
and it's a behavior if you think about
the person that you want to become
what's that person do every day that you
don't do right now
and when you start to do the thing that
the person you want to become is doing
you leverage something called behavioral
activation therapy and that is a whole
body of research that says when you act
like the person you want to become it's
the most powerful way to change a habit
it's even uh better therapy than uh talk
therapy because the action proves to
your brain that you're becoming that
person you're seeing the change through
the action and so then the brain catches
up and starts to relate to you like a
person that's confident or a person who
adores their appearance or a person that
celebrates themselves exactly as they
are first of all stop talking about
passion stop talking about launching a
business okay when you think about it
too big
it will paralyze you
if you're lucky and you're in a position
where your bills are getting paid and
you have the luxury of being able to try
to think about what you want to do in
this next chapter
um here's where I want you to start I
want you to start with what energizes
you now how ironic is that given that
I'm speaking at the energetic Women's
Conference here in Indianapolis today
why am I saying energizes you and what
do I talk what am I talking about when I
say energize when I say energizes you
I'm asking you what is it that you're
curious about what is it that you feel
so
expanded you feel energized you feel
kind of excited whenever you're doing it
you're in a phase when you're just
trying to figure out what's your next
move of just paying attention to your
curiosity paying attention to the things
that interest you the truth is passion
is Just Energy if you're passionate
about something it means you're
energized when you do it so let's
reverse engineer this and let's
just give yourself a simple question
what are you curious about
and if you
allow yourself
or things
energize you
my friend will start to find the clues
about what it is that you should and
could be doing because all the research
says that if you're doing something that
you like
doing something that curious about
really going to enjoy it you're going to
be really good at it because if you like
doing it you'll spend more time doing
that you're going to get better at it we
moved to Vermont I got a brand new uh
primary care doctor
and I thought he said something really
interesting he's this great guy
um he settled here because his wife's
family is from Vermont and so he's now
lived here for 40 years and at the end
of my uh first appointment with them he
said a really interesting thing to me he
kind of chuckled because of course I'm
very entertaining and bubbly and all
this stuff and he said it's going to be
really fun to watch what happens to you
and I'm like
what doctor says that to somebody
and I said what do you mean and he said
well I'll tell you Mel in the years that
I've been practicing as a primary care
doctor in southern Vermont I have seen
so many people moved to Vermont
they're seeking a quieter lifestyle
they're seeking a change a new chapter
and what I find is if you're what you're
actually seeking is a safe haven and
you're running away from your problems
a funny thing happens
your problems always go with you and
when you move somewhere very quiet
the Solitude just magnifies that you
were trying to get away from
and so if you're starting a new chapter
because you're excited and you're
Reinventing yourself that's fabulous
still take time to complete the last
chapter that you were in so you step
into the new chapter with all of the
wisdom and the Gratitude and the
learning and the growth that you gained
if you are starting a new chapter as so
many of us do because we are running
away from the old us we're running away
from a bad relationship we're closing
the door on something that wasn't
working
you better make sure you take the time
to think through and journal about this
last chapter who you've been the habits
you no longer want to repeat the
mistakes that you made what you've
learned what you're running from and
more importantly what changes you're
going to make and how this new chapter
is going to support you in doing it and
in becoming the person that you're meant
to be without that intentional moment of
reflection and without that intentional
moment where you're going to list out
the behaviors and thinking patterns and
habits you're changing
my doctor's right you're just going to
take all that crap you're running from
right into this new chapter I know that
in this next chapter that I consciously
create I want to have more fun I want to
I Really Wanna Love the process yeah I
don't want to make it so hard on myself
and be gripping everything so tight and
it's really easy for me to see it in
other people because I know what it
feels like in here I'm working hard to
break the patterns that still hold me
back and the big one that holds me back
is
um bulldozing that's the it's it's it's
literally when I start to feel any level
of tension this is particularly true in
my marriage
um I'm married to a saint thank God
Chris Robbins meditates every morning
it's the only reason why we've lasted 26
years
um so he puts up with me when I feel my
like whatever emotion rise I immediately
raise my voice
it's how I assert power in the
relationship
and I am so committed Louis to
breaking that pattern wow and being a
more fun person to be around and a
Kinder person to be around there are 7.5
billion people on this incredible Planet
verse but do you know how many of them
you're responsible for truly one you see
while you're busy taking care of
everybody else who is it that's taking
care of you you were given one human
being one Mind One Soul one body one
life we are so bananas focused about
what people who know nothing
about what's going on in your life think
and what happens is you can get so
concerned about the opinions and the
judgments of all these other people that
you're taking care of and that you're
being nice to that you forget about the
one person's opinion that actually
matters and that's yours and when
silencing yourself and being way more
concerned about what everybody thinks
becomes a pattern you are holding
yourself back you don't go after your
dreams because you're way too caught up
in what everybody else is thinking for
every person that's got a side eye or an
eye roll or an opinion about what you're
doing I promise you when you make the
decision to live your life for you the
right people will find you is this going
to be easy to chart your own path to
hear what people have to say but not let
it Define what you do next it's going to
take a little bit of practice but once
you make the decision to live your life
for you I promise you everything will
fall into place sometimes when the dream
is so big the fact that it's so big
becomes paralyzing because you think
about where you are right now and you
think holy cow that thing that I really
want I don't even like how do you even
start when the dream is so big
so here's what we're going to do today
we're going to shrink it down because
you know me I am all about Simplicity
I'm all about making sure that the
advice works for you because if it
doesn't work for you you're not going to
do it and I'm all about switching how
you think about things making this
smaller and making it something that I'm
learning about rather than doing and
launching and hmm that somehow thinking
about it differently frees up the
ability to get started if I get you to
start doing that and you do this every
day for 10 or 15 minutes which you
absolutely can guess what's going to
happen
you're going to feel momentum you're
gonna feel like you're working on it
you're going to meet people that are
interested in it you're going to learn
things that are going to lead to the
next thing that you need to learn and
you will have mastered the art of
getting started and by doing something a
little bit every day you're also going
to master the art of continuing to keep
going and from there it'll snowball I
promise you how does your favorite
sports team begin the game
by high-fiving each other to send
yourself out into the game but when
researchers actually studied NBA teams
they could predict who's going to be the
most successful teams at the end of the
season and who's going to be at the
bottom of the league based on one
characteristic at the beginning of the
season in the preseason and that is how
many times does the team in the
preseason do fist bumps high fives or
pats on the back and what they found is
it's the teams that do that the most in
the beginning have the winningest record
and the reason the question is why well
the reason why is these gestures are
more than gestures they're symbols of
trust and partnership they build
momentum and so many of us are
struggling in life with people pleasing
and guilt and all of these emotions
because we have broken that partnership
with ourselves and this is a way every
morning after brushing your teeth we're
going to stack this habit put the
toothbrush down pick up your hand look
yourself in the mirror and say how am I
going to show up for that human being
today and seal it with a high five
that's it gotta raise your own game and
so what is the game that you play at
work you got to get out of the head that
it's all about you
the best team members are always
thinking about how to make the team
better the best team members are loyal
to the team the best people to work with
are the ones that are in it together and
so in order for you to get your toxic
colleague to shift Behavior you gotta
model it and here's the interesting
thing about the research when people are
working with co-workers or on a team
where people collaborate and where you
have honest conversations it creates
what we call psychological safety which
basically just means I feel safe working
with you I know that if I come to you
with feedback you listen I know that if
I tell you how your behavior is
impacting me you'll actually care I know
that if you need help you'll come to me
and I know if I need help I can come to
you that's what psychological safety
means you're a safe person and hopefully
a fun person to work with so you've got
to model that that means you got to ask
for support that means you've got to
have direct collaborate or direct
conversations and it means you got to
support your team members too and do you
realize
that when you work with other people
that do this team members are 35 times
more likely to show visible commitment
to your success and they're 47 percent
more likely when you model it to work
hard to build and maintain your trust
so don't ever get resigned in thinking
that the way that you behave won't
impact has somebody else is behaving
around you let me explain what happens
to this really interesting concept
called ghosts in the nursery
and so trauma patterns get automated and
because they're not experienced in your
brain they're felt in your nervous
system
and so it's why you can have a pattern
from your past but be completely unaware
that it's running your life right now
because it's stored not in your
conscious thought but in your nervous
system and you feel it in your body
before it even gets into your head and
so from there's this concept called
ghost in the nursery which basically
means there's all kinds of that goes on
when you're little that you may or may
not remember in your mind but your body
remembers it so for example if you had
parents that were just stressed out and
they come home and they've been busy and
you're sitting there playing on the
floor and there's there's toys
everywhere and Mom or Dad's reaction to
a mess is to scream
that creates this kind of thing in your
nervous system now you may not remember
that episode that happened on May 17
1972 but your nervous system remembers
what it's like so fast forward You're
Now 51 years old
and you walk in the house and there's a
mess everywhere and even though you have
said I'm not going to bulldoze and yell
at anybody
my body recognizes the situation so what
do you do you repeat the pattern you saw
and so what I'm working on right now is
a pattern that is encoded in my nervous
system
I was trying to create a video yes or
two days ago
um for share the mic for share the mic
now
um trying to create a video and I'm like
doing take after take because I want to
get it right and my daughter comes
Waltzing into the room and was like how
long are you gonna be doing this
and I was like why can't you
say it I literally like screamed at her
and she looked at me Louis
and she goes
you have a real problem wow how old's
your daughter
20. and I said I I calmly said you're
right I do
when I get interrupted
I lose control of the response and I'm
working so hard and the way that you and
I'm clearly not mastering this yet but
the way that you do it is as you feel it
rise up
you have to you know you can use the
five second rule five four three two one
you can use just take a quick breath you
can notice the pattern and you've got to
create a pause between the emotion
rising up and the reaction that gets
automated and for many people the
reaction Lewis is to run away
it's to leave the room it's to avoid the
confrontation the it was just easy you
know hold on let me let the clock go
even though you hate being erupted by
anything this is the greatest I did like
I didn't do it I didn't do the bulldoze
I was I was calm because it wasn't a
human being I'm only mean to human
beings
um I know like I a lot of people run
away they avoid conflict they say it's
just easier
but if running away and avoiding
conflict continues to create a pattern
where you feel invisible and your
boundaries are tromped on that's a
pattern and you know here's the other
thing about patterns running away and
being quiet might have saved you when
you were little because if you were
quiet and out of the room you didn't get
hit you didn't get yelled at you were
out of Harm's Way so when you were
little it was a genius pattern because
it protected you but the issue for
adults is that again we walk around with
the patterns that we created when we
were eight years old in different
situations than we are in now and now we
are completely a robot to these patterns
the reason why it's so important to
start with a friend cleanse and I'm sure
a lot of you how many of you heard that
and you thought oh my God getting rid of
people oh boy oh boy I'm gonna cleanse
these friends
yes and no
a friend cleanse is critical because the
single most influential thing around you
are the people that you hang out with
and if you have relationships that are
toxic if you have relationships that
cause guilt if you have relationships
that are creating drama in your life if
you have relationships that are not
Equitable guess what that's creating the
overwhelm that's creating unhappiness
that's
keeping you doubting yourself if you
have friends that um have bad habits
guess what that's making it really
really hard for you to change your
habits for the good jealousy is one of
the most powerful directional signals on
the planet
because you're only jealous of people
that are doing things or have things
that you actually want it's impossible
to be fake jealous whatever you're
jealous of is hitting something deeply
personal
pay attention to it instead of stewing
in it go oh flip it
that's interesting I wonder why I'm
jealous what is it about it oh it's that
they're doing it consistently it's that
they've built a team it's that they've
aligned their work together so that
they're spending more time together huh
how could I take those things that I'm
really now really inspired by
and take action and go get them in my
life because the thing about jealousy is
it's just your inspiration that's
blocked
jealousy is sort of the insecurity
that you have that blocks this
inspiration I guarantee you back to the
Uber driver he's jealous of all the
other actors earning Oscars
because he's so inspired by the thought
of doing that in his own life but his
insecurity is blocking action his fear
is blocking action so instead of it
being inspiration
it shows up as jealousy and I'm here to
tell you the second you feel jealousy
freaking stop okay let's unpack that
what exactly is it about it and now if I
were inspired by it because there's
enough success to go around for
everybody if I can use that as a road
map to then go figure out how I might be
able to do that for myself
wow talk about a game changer and now
let's add in the high five what if every
time I took a little step I celebrated
myself for just doing it now you're
building small wins and momentum in a
Direction that's meant for you that's
how you change your life as is the case
in life you're always going to be
growing and when you hit new chapters in
your life it's really important to be
deliberate and mindful about the people
that you spend time with and who you
surround yourself with does that mean
you got to ditch your high school
friends absolutely not but it might mean
that you shouldn't spend as much time
with them it might mean that you should
show up to those friendships a little
bit differently and maybe they'll go a
little bit deeper and it definitely
means that based on where you are in
your life right now that you should get
more proactive about surrounding
yourself with a group of new friends or
current friends that are up to the same
kind of growth that you are often times
when you hit bottom you bounce
and that's where I think the power is
that you when the world feels upside
down you always have the power to make
it right when one chapter ends you
always have the power to write a new one
when you know you feel like nobody loves
you you have the power to learn how to
love yourself and if there's one thing
that covid-19 has done regardless of
whatever Devastation it has caused in
your life is it has forced us all to
experience the great pause
and I read that in a medium article and
I loved that idea of a pause because I
think in 2020 our lives have gotten so
fast and so digital and when you are
forced to pause and get present and to
slow down you are reminded of what's
actually important
and what's important is your health
what's important is your family and your
friends what's important is whether or
not you are taking care of yourself and
thinking positive thoughts versus
negative thoughts the world gave us a
gigantic experiment where we got to
practice and get to continue to practice
the most important skill in the planet
which is emotional resilience the
ability to face hard
and actually be okay the ability to face
the uncertain and redirect your
attention on things that you know that
are certain and if you want more fire
and special videos check out the one
that we recently did the link is right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there